all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
comer and today we'll be going over the
games of Grayson Marx you might remember
this uh this kid from games that end in
eight moves number two published a year
ago today are there is about and you
know he was on the receiving end of some
eight move victories and another good
end but bottom line is his games get
over really quick so let's see how he's
progressed in a year to see how he's
playing now so he played in the Friday
action quads last week that's three
games against people in about the 1000
category and game in twenty minutes with
a three second delay
believe it or not he took chess notation
and slowed down a lot and obviously he
played more than eight moves big spoiler
alert
alright so Grayson has the white pieces
against Agastya and he starts out d4 so
somebody along the way taught Grayson
how to play the Stonewall attack or
defense or just the Stonewall all right
so so the Stonewall you get a formation
as we'll see here but the good thing
about it is no matter what black really
plays you can do the Stonewall and this
is basically the setup okay so
regardless of what what black is doing
because we're going to move our F pawn
up to or D pawn up to and then our C and
E pawn will protect them then we'll get
our Knights hopping around and this
Bishop on d3 this long diagonal where
you can possibly have Bishop takes h7
check in the future or you know a queen
checkmate up there so so the bishop up
there is pretty pretty good okay so this
is pretty much
the Stonewall and we'll see that his two
games are very similar to each other all
right so he gets castled
and now white gets castled rook to e8 a
weird spot for the rook because he's
really not going to push 'if i've
all right so Grayson gets a little bit
of head of himself and plays efore can
anybody tell me why that is a mistake
well which Square so so let's look at
what this pawn was doing on III so we
was supporting the D pawn and the F pawn
right so when he plays efore what can we
simply take in this position so we could
take the pone on d4 that's true we go
with our Knight we can take the pawn on
e4 or we could take the pawn on f4 for
free right all right so that's that's
the move they should play okay it's like
a free pawn
oh hey he got too too ahead of himself
okay but we do have to take a pawn
because if we waste a move here what
move is white going to play to punish us
'if I've excellent and do you know what
the worst move to play in this position
is Knight takes e5 and then you're still
in the fork right and a bad news right
so don't don't get him tangled up so we
do have to take something and Agassi the
tides to take the e pawn
so it takes the epon right and now he
Forks white guys but luckily there's two
guys that can take so Knight takes e4 so
Queenie 7 once again he's doing too much
on the e-file when he's got no no ideas
ever to push this EEP on so they're
really just clogged back there he should
be thinking of different ways to get his
piece is active so Knight to e5 so once
again what would be the worst move in
this position the knight right you don't
want to take this knight with the knight
instead you know Bishop takes pawn takes
Knight takes Bishop takes so notice
notice on blacks King side here right
well his castles on he's got no
defenders over here of his King side
Castle the Queen isn't really doing too
much of a good job this is very scary so
this is this is times where you want to
start striking as white and remember the
bishop is lined up with this h7 point
here so so bad things can happen the
rook is lined up on this f7 square so so
very bad so black decides he's going to
attack the bishop and play f5 so does
everybody know a possible move White has
to capture the F pawn
so there's two no there's three ways we
can capture the f-pawn here can anybody
tell me how the rule could take it true
the bishop could take it and then
there's one other move to capture this
pawn yes you can capture it on percent
whenever a pawn moves up two spaces and
lands on the same rank on the adjourn
e-file there you can capture the pawn on
percent now now when he played it white
even though he's rated about well 990
about a thousand he went ballistic here
he was like he can't do it because
because he didn't take the conventional
route to getting to the e square you see
so this is the guy that ended up doing
the on percent right as we watch okay so
here was like well that wasn't his
original a pawn to get there so he can't
do on percent okay it doesn't matter
which point it is if there's a pawn
there and you go up two spaces and it
lands directly next to it I don't care
how it got there it has the ability to
do on passant
all right so now so now blacks out of
the game he's very distracted now about
the opposite rule so you just got to get
over it you know the TD ruled correctly
so time to move on with the game so pawn
takes and now White has a good move
anybody see a good move see a check play
a check rate check alert so Queen blocks
should white trade Queens in this
position know exactly you're on the
attack okay don't trade so there's a lot
of different lines you can do but Queen
h5 is the best keep the pressure on
all right so now you tax the bishop
should the bishop take the knight no no
you don't want to get rid of one of your
attackers right instead we can attack
the Queen that's pretty cool
so now Queen attacks the Queen
unfortunately we're going to have to
trade the Queen or Bishop is going to go
bye-bye right so he takes connects the
pawns now Bishop has to take well he
doesn't have to take but he does Bishop
takes so White had a nice attack going
with this check but but he never he
never really got his rook up to there
and over so he had a trade and now you
know it's looking a pretty draws to
because they have opposite colored
bishops and the same amount of points so
if you were playing black in this
position would you want to get your King
toward the center of the board or would
you want to get them to the side of the
board and keep in mind you're attacking
a bishop if you get them to the side of
the board
Center right yeah yeah you want your
King in the center you want them to
become a warrior here if he just hangs
out on the side the the chances of
Ingunn checkmated go up and the chances
that you won't be a factor at all in the
game go up as well but he gets an attack
and Gration sees that so he retreats
so bishop attacks the pawn do we want to
try and save this pawn or do we're going
to be like I don't really care so what
are some ways we can guard this pawn
which rook there's through different
rooks we can use right
the rook yeah because if we use this
rook this rook might be doing too much
he's protecting the sea pawn and also
the e pawn so we'll give this rook a job
to do and he protects all right so now
this work gets over so he can start
thinking about checking so Bishop
attacks this pawn so he moves it
Bishop attacks the rook so you can first
throw in this check or you could just
just move it over whatever he wants so
now he's got two guys coming down on the
e pawn but it's protected by the bishop
and the rook so so not that big of a
threat so King over he doesn't want to
get checked on the h-file and so Bishop
checksum good so now the Kings making a
run for it all right but let's see if he
can get there in time so Bishop the g3
kind of not what you wanted to do
because he probably wants to get this
rook on the H file here but all right
Bishop to g3 and so now g5 so what is
the threat for black here
yes he's got to fork them but Grayson
gets a big smile on his face he thinks
he's got a trick so he's going to play
h4 and let this happen
big mistake so but he knows a way out
here so so how can we not let pawn takes
rook happen or pawn takes Bishop how can
we make that an impossibility for black
to play
right so we that's called a pin so we
put this pawn in absolute pin do we want
to do it with this rook or with this
rook this one well there's two two
reasons why we don't do that one well
one well one reason is bishop could take
it and then we're still in the same
predicament and the second reason is
even if we couldn't take it we could
just step out of the pin and now one of
them is going to have to go okay so so
he chooses the one that's you know
entangled in this and gets them in all
right
so now he steps out of the pin and white
steps back so we have which which is not
the best move here but there's not many
good moves for a white here so how can
we as black in this position as a Goss
do how can we try well if we can't get
them so Bishop attacks the rook good
move
okay and now he plays rook to h3 alright
now now we have a definite chance to win
a piece here for black just move the
pawn excellent so we attack the rook so
the rooks got to move right you can move
the h1 you can move the d3 and then
which move do we do to win a piece here
same thing right just move the pawn up
and now where's this Bishop going to go
the answer no where well I'm sure he'll
take he'll get the most out of it for
them rook takes check but we'll be fine
right
and we'll we'll have we'll have a full
piece up on our opponent so that would
be pretty good alright unfortunately
even though graison is begging to be
attacked instead agassi plays a very not
the best move he takes the pawn here so
G takes h4 and and so now it's it's not
looking too good for him so you just
take it right and now he attacks but is
that is that really can king capture
protected pieces no so so if the King's
attacking people it's better that they
attack players that are undefended
because it's an actual threat right so
so white it totally ignores the threat
because it's not a threat and checksum
is like go back King and so the King is
going back and now what can we take as
white now we don't want to take the
bishop we want to take stuff that's free
right so they take the free point right
so now rook attacks the rook do we want
to trade here or do we want to try to
get checkmate yeah move the rook check
them King once again he attacks the rook
but it's a fake threat so we can check
them again so now the King's forced to
the seventh rank only well tie f7 right
that's his only legal move all right so
so we check them get them over to the G
file
oh yeah well yeah why didn't he go here
good question yeah good question he
actually should have yeah you want to
you want to get you want to get as far
away as these rooks as possible so King
the g8 hiding in a corner with open
files not a good idea all right so
another check and so obviously if this
bishop wasn't here right
we'd have we'd have checkmate
but unfortunately the bishop is there
and we can't take our own pieces so so
he moves this rook to check King over
check King up seven so so he's actually
trying he's actually doing a solid for
the guy bringing him over here but he's
gonna he's got a plan check King up now
I was actually watching the game right
now at this point I came in a little
late and I was like I was screaming in
my head obviously it with a stoic face
because I'm not I'm at armor director I
can't give up any anything I was like oh
man you got a check King there and this
is you know you know this is pretty good
you got them in the discovery you can
check but then he just comes up here and
now your works attack and your tax kind
of dead so it goes see what I know all
right so what is whites great move here
it takes them it takes them two moves to
find it but but he eventually gets the
job done I like it to the Jeep to the G
square yeah and then shoot games over
right I mean you ain't you ain't gonna
recover from this so that's way better
than my plan and way better than his
plan he plays Bishop the g3
unfortunately had to attack the pawn and
now if black is resourceful he could try
to find a way out of here but but he
doesn't he just protects the pawn and
now Grayson knows rook g2 g7 is going to
be a killer move and a gasser is going
to make it real easy for him he's going
to put up no resistance here and
everybody see the mate this rook or this
rook the one on the right I like yeah
checkmate game over
all right so that was great since a big
victory so a good job for Grayson
and so now Grayson is two and oh and if
you win
well actually I take it all back he's
won and won but if he if he wins uh this
game he'll get five dollars so so he's
really pumped to play and guess what
he's going to play the exact same
opening this is not a repeat okay this
is this is actually round three okay
look pretty familiar right yes - all
right it's like you're not going to get
through it it's going to be really hard
so so the right way
well not the right way but but a way you
could play against this is black instead
of putting your knight in front of the C
pawn is trying to break it open with c5
but I mean it's still tough to break
through because it's Stonewall right but
what are the disadvantages of it how
about your bishop doesn't get the play
but I mean the good thing about it is uh
you know you're not getting checkmated
and you know you're doing pretty well
alright so and and black is cramped
right I mean look at me the same thing
before but once again he makes the same
mistake so so you know he's got the
first you know one two three four five
six seven eight moves down pretty well
but then then he messes up each and
every time right so what should we
capture as black in this position
well you which one because remember we
can take you have the one on the right
right yeah we need to take that okay if
they're going to give you a free pawn
you need to take it all right
right but instead they take this guy
Knight takes Queen eise Evan Knight to
e5 okay so how should we take this
Knight or do we even want to take the
knight anybody have any any suggestions
the way we don't want to take the knight
obviously as Knight takes e5 right
because then we get fourth right so
let's not walk into those pawn Forks all
right so it takes the knight Bishop
captures Knight takes pawn takes so
those are Bishop on d6 have anywhere to
go no because they're all occupied all
his flight squares are occupied by a
pawn attacks okay so he decides to make
a threat greater or equal to Grayson's
okay so if you were playing white here
what would you play love it love it love
it and then if he plays rook here well
we don't want to go back we don't want
to go all the way back all the way back
is that what you mean I like it so so
there's no reason to ever trade an
active piece right for a trap piece
right because this Bishop is trapped
still it did nothing to do that so just
retreat it back and then he still got to
deal with that he's probably just got to
take it you know so good it's that
Greyson you know he knew all about that
on percent and how much it distressed
the kid from last game he was like all
right I'll do one percent again but by
doing a percent
now you know taking the bishop is off
the table so so big mistake but the kid
the kid already conceded that his bishop
was was gone so he makes a dubious move
here Bishop takes check so you know it
happens so so Kings can capture pieces
if they're not defended so he takes and
I gets another check-in but he just
retreats the safety and now rook takes
rook takes King takes and once again he
gets the Queen to g4 check in King up
takes a free pawn and it prevents the
rook from coming up here so the rook
goes to h8 now let's all let's all pay
attention here all right and let's try
to figure out how to beat a beat the kid
playing black Neil as fast as possible
that's not really bishop g6 why wouldn't
you check with the most powerful piece
because because by playing Bishop to g6
so now you're cutting off the Queen from
the attack right you don't want to do
that because guess who's going to end up
probably checkmating the Queen right
maybe in this instance the bishop but
most likely the Queen right Queen to g6
much better all right so so if you
really wanted to keep playing he would
you would try to flee that way but it
will all be in vain anyway so King up be
bringing the bishop get everybody in the
attack right well he doesn't but but I
add it's still good
let's verify eventually going to lead to
mate but I guess I guess we have Queen
to f6 check and now the King only has
one legal move right well well yeah in
the game Grayson action does take the
rook but we could do even better than
that
bishop g6 checkmate even though the
computer is not yelling about it but
trust us it's betas
there's no way the King can go because
the Queen's getting it and there's
nothing that can block it so it's all
over checkmate all right we got to have
one more game in I've been teaching at
an elementary school in a South st.
Louis the last few weeks so I pitted uh
one of my best kids with the black
pieces against a kid that's still
learning a little bit and I made them
play this variation to see hey you know
you won't lose so much pieces if you
play this the Stonewall ok but so so
this is the position we set up and you
know we went through the opening and
they got to this position
Aristotle's playing a black and he plays
Bishop to d6 which is you know common in
these games okay so so white's idea
should be like Knight f3 Castle say he
plays g3 no real reason to play g3 here
because your Bishop is already out and
has a beautiful diagonal all right so so
Aristotle gets castled and so he's going
to go for an attack okay I can't I can't
really blame them so unfortunately it is
a black that makes a mistake here which
which kind of surprised me and how come
this is such a dreadful mistake free
piece right clean takes and now what is
a white threatening checkmate right
so so he attacks the Queen and stops the
checkmate all along which is good so he
flees his Queen all the way to the back
a six all right so maybe he wants to get
his Bishop out this way so b3 what do
you think is a decent move for white in
this position here though how about just
h5 trying to break open the H file and
get a checkmate so maybe maybe his up
instead of fleeing all the way back to
d1 maybe could have stopped at like e 2
and then if you know he's going to do
all this we take take and then we can
slide our Queen over and threaten you
know checkmate again but okay alright so
so in the game the game actually
precedes a a6 and then B 3 and we might
have lost the game all right so b5 is
not played black plays the move f6 even
though I told him you know
don't play f6 so White's going to bring
his NATO and black plays the move b5 so
white gets castled here and black gets
his [ __ ] about Bishop to b7 and so now
White's it he's got to keep going with
the King side attack here g4 + f5 ok
he's going to try to stop the marching
other pawns so so when you play you know
especially if you don't have much
experience playing she'll always ask
yourself why did you play that move f5
right well obviously it's attacking
something right so unfortunately I mean
this is easy to see attack attack
instead he decides to play on the
opposite side of the board
a three and then pawn takes g4 remember
just because they take something yours
or land on a square because they
captured something they might have
alternative motives to be there right
like okay I wanted to get the pawn but I
also am attacking stuff and so as we'll
see a spiral happens here that that he
can't get out of rook f2 pawn takes
Knight luckily this time he does see oh
my God my Queens attack and takes it and
now you see there's another free pawn
for for Aristotle the one on the right
yep so there's something you can take
from this lesson just capture all the
stuff on the right all right and then
Queen takes the pole and rook back you
can't resist the check rook over and
Queen to h4
so it moves this Queen to d2 and now
Aristotle he's just making a tax right
so if you can just see it's a tax at
first you need to identify the threats
that's that's important start
identifying the threats and then to
figuring out how to defend the threats
so what is the threat right now
b3 does b4 does that satisfy the threat
no because any hops write it in good so
remember they might not be disappear
they might be attacking squares he
doesn't really want your pawn he really
wants to get to be three to four your
queen and rook all right so so so Queen
c2 you know it looks good in theory
because wow you know I playing Queen c2
I'm going to come down and take your
pawn like if you if you like mess around
I'm going to take your pawn he doesn't
even want to take it and and whatever
we're going to take your pawn and then
we're going to checkmate you right the
quiz over there okay but in any event
all right if we play Queen c2 what move
can black play it is just like you're
not gonna do any of that stuff you can
check you and you scare because you're
going to only go to h2 right scary it's
pretty scary I would be scared so all
your dreams are down the down the drain
okay
I mean really instead of check I mean he
might be able to just take it take it
anyway and then then check you but
probably check you first and scare you
so
so alright so Queen c2 doesn't work
unfortunately but but it was it's a
great idea though but of course you
can't give up this e1 square was at it
only the Queen could protect it we're
doomed
Bishop c2 there you go
you just retreat good okay alright but
instead he plays a plays another move
that isn't the championship move plays a
queen to e2 so we got the Queen out of
the danger but but now that the bishop
and the rook are in danger so what is
the best move now to try to salvage
something out of a bad situation
22 b2 or a queen bee well the bad thing
about Queen B 2 again is oh man
Bishop b2 okay - so we much rather lose
in exchange then lose a whole piece
outright okay like if we could save the
rook but we can't even save the rook in
this position because if rook a to
happens you just get forked again so
it's a semana so don't let you know your
opponent's in your territory if you have
ways to stop them okay because once you
give up all this space and control your
whole position is just going to start
crumbling okay and it can become even
worse than you can possibly imagine all
right but uh but you're not going to
like what he does all right Knight takes
Bishop c1 and here goes again
and I got your Bishop oh but I get your
knight ha ha but yeah you kind of came
out on the wrong end of this buddy all
right
and
and so yeah whites in trouble so Bishop
takes pawn and then after this move of
whites we just had to call it a day
can anybody guess what that move was
what's the worst move on the board for
white or it could be the best move white
has no chances of winning so sometimes
you just got to go go all out and just
hope hope he doesn't see that oh I got
your queen but Aristotle is too astute
gets a check and and then yeah he just
goes for the throat now Bishop c1 rook
up take all your pieces and it's like
okay no more no more no more if we can't
bear to watch anymore so so it worked
well for a kid that dropped all his
pieces you know it took them you know
took him 28 moves to drop all his pieces
essentially because he played the
Stonewall here so let's go over the
Stonewall one more time so you know if
you have if you have trouble in the
opening like oh why do I lose all my
pieces so fast
well you can try the Stonewall so it
really doesn't matter what black does
you can get that's okay that's okay you
can get this setup you know you have
complete control over the e5 square and
you know it's pretty good alright your
Bishop and Knight are going to have to
get a plan to get in the game but you
know at least you're not going to lose
them right off the bat right and so
though it's a decent opening all right
so that's the Stonewall for you thank
you very much